in fact just this past monday night
i received a letter from the justice
department informing the judiciary
committee
that it will now categorically refuse to
send key officials to our hearings
because attorney general barr did not
like the questions he was asked
during his appearance before the
committee in july
and when congress is sued to enforce its
rights in courts
we have been forced into a years-long
process that may enable the
administration to simply run out of the
clock
it has been more than a year since we
sued to compel testimony from don mcgann
the primary source of the mueller
report's detailed examination
of the president's pattern of
obstruction of justice
that case continues to work its way
through the courts
similar delays of greeted lawsuits for
related grand jury materials
for president trump's financial records
and for other important information
critical to our oversight work that is
why the protecting our democracy act
incorporates congresswoman madeline
dean's bill which provides an expedited
streamlined process for the house and
senate
to enforce the subpoenas in the courts
and to ensure that we can conduct proper
oversight
we've also witnessed brazen efforts by
the administration to undermine the rule
of law by interfering with pending cases
at the department of justice on matters
that directly implicate the president
whether it was the rogers stone
sentencing the michael flynn prosecution
or the russia investigation the white
house has threatened
bullied and intimidated the department
into doing the president's personal
bidding
that is why the legislation includes the
first ever requirement
that the attorney general maintain a log
of certain contacts with the white house
for review by the inspector general as
if necessary by congress
this builds on the legislation chairman
jeffries has led this congress
when the nation's founders wrote the
constitution they stood fast to a key
principle
that the executive must be accountable
to congress to the people
and ultimately to the rule of law it is
vital
that we reassert this important
principle i am proud to join my
colleagues in introducing the protecting
our democracy act
so that we may restore these and other
checks and balances
that are so fundamental to our democracy
as i bring on uh congresswoman maloney i
want to
join the distinguished chairman in
acknowledging legislation of other
members of congress that are contained
in and the chairman's
uh legislation that they are putting
forth uh
uh and cheer women's and i also want to
acknowledge maxine waters is doing some
very
important work on this subject not part
of this package
but part of uh preserving our our
democracy
with that i'm pleased to yield to the
distinguished chairwoman of the
uh governor foreman oversight committee
counci
marum chair carolyn malone
good morning i'm proud to stand here
with speaker pelosi
and my colleagues in government many of
whom are with us chairing committees
that have produced this legislation
and i'm very pleased to join them in
introducing the
protecting our democracy act to prevent
presidential abuses of power and
strengthen
advocacy and transparency and
accountability
former oversight chairman elijah
cummings often said
we are in a fight for the soul of our
democracy
we are witnessing a president who
retaliates
against whistleblowers and inspectors
general obstructs
investigations to root out waste fraud
and abuse
and openly mocks the law it must stop
we have an obligation to take immediate
action to rein in this
terrible behavior this landmark
legislation will strengthen protections
for inspector generals by only allowing
an ig to be removed for specific
reasons and prevent them from being
fired
for political retaliation i
introduced the inspector general
independence act with
majority leader hoyer and several other
members
after president trump retaliated against
inspectors general
at the department of defense the
department of transportation
state department and other agencies
this package also increases protections
for whistleblowers who expose waste
fraud and abuse the trump administration
has gained
engaged in a sustained assault
on whistleblowers federal workers have
been harassed
fired embarrassed demoted
i introduced the whistleblower
protection and improvement act
along with oversight subcommittee chair
jerry conley
to give whistleblowers the opportunity
to challenge
retaliation in court and prohibit
disclosing
a whistleblower's identity
whistleblowers helped our committee
expose abuses in the white house
security clearance process
the administration's nuclear deal with
saudi arabia
and investigations into ethics abuses
and mismanagement
at the postal service and the census
department
by administration officials this package
of reforms
also closes loopholes that president
trump has exploited
by installing unqualified people
as acting agency heads and inspector
general
finally the bill helps ensure that the
line between official business
and political activity is not erased
the trump administration has openly
mocked and violated the hatch act
for example former senior adviser
kellyanne conway
broke the law dozens of times and the
office of the special counsel
recommended that she be fired president
trump refused to act
recently he used the white house and
other federal landmarks
for partisan political purposes during
the republican
national convention white house chief of
staff mark meadows said and i quote
nobody outside the beltway really cares
about the hatch act
end quote he's wrong taxpayers
care they expect their money to be used
for legitimate
government activities and not for
partisan
political campaigning the protecting our
democracy act
authorizes the office of special counsel
to fine
senior political appointees up to fifty
thousand dollars
if they break the law and the president
refuses to hold them
accountable this bill ensures that no
one is above the law
and that all employees are held
accountable
for their actions now it is my honor to
introduce the distinguished chair of the
budget committee
representative yarmouth
thank you madam chair good morning
everyone
there is perhaps no clear intent of the
framers of the constitution
than that the congress of the united
states should have the power of the post
the power to
decide how to raise and spend the
people's money
that is the sole prerogative of the
congress
the president's role as embodied in his
oath of office
is to faithfully execute the laws
of the country in this case in the
relevant case
congressional appropriations of course
throughout history
many presidents have tried to circumvent
congressional
spending decisions in order to advance
their own
personal agendas or philosophical
agendas
and on three different at least three
different occasions congress
tried to push back on that by setting
some guard rails as we've
mentioned several times already today
first time in 1884 the anti-deficiency
act which
prohibits the president from spending
money that has not been appropriated by
congress
the second time in 1974
when they created the we created the
empowerment control act
which was to prevent the administration
from not spending from refusing to spend
funding
that has been appropriated by the
congress
and then creating the government
accountability office which is an
independent
agency whose mission is to oversee
the spending activity of the various
administrations
despite these guard rails these
undis undermining of congressional
authority has
continued to take place and i don't
think there's ever been
a more brazen violator of the
power of the purse than donald trump
uh what's made it worse is it's not in
advance of
the times he's using it used it is not
in advance of
some philosophical agenda it's his own
personal political
agenda we saw that when he tried to
withhold
funding for ukraine in order to get
assistance in his reelection campaign
that brought one of the articles of
impeachment that we uh we passed in the
house
when he's moved military funding to pay
for
the mexican wall rather than having the
mexicans pay for it
he used military appropriated funds and
even within the last
10 days threatening to withhold funding
to cities
whose policies he doesn't like and who
thinks
that they are anarchical in some way
so for all of these reasons i introduced
a bill called the congressional power of
the purse act and that is
title five of the protecting our
democracy act
has three major tenets it restores
congress
congress's central role in funding
decisions
it increases transparency and
accountability
on the behalf of the administration
through omb and it strengthens
strengthens existing budgetary law
in a number of ways the reporting
requirements through requiring
congressional uh gratification of
decisions to withhold funding
to require the department of justice to
investigate
any illegality that the government
accountability
office may may find and finally by
imposing penalties on those who violate
the law
uh unfortunately the the anti-deficiency
act
which again was passed in 1884 has
authorizes penalties uh the empowerment
control act doesn't so if you violate
the empowerment control act
it's okay you broke the law so what well
we changed those
flaws and loopholes and again strengthen
the the existing guard rails
to so that we can reassert the power of
congress
to uh raise and spend the people's money
uh it's now my privilege to introduce a
video
uh with uh chairwoman lofgren
your turn
what many of us set out to achieve in
congress but after
four years of the most corrupt
presidential administration
in modern history they've become
urgently leaders three years ago i
worked on the staff of my predecessor
economist and don
edwards one of my assignments was
working with the judiciary committee
on the impeachment of president richard
nixon after president nixon resigned
the congress enacted a series of
landmark laws and reforms
to change the way politics was conducted
and to prevent a future president from
similarly abusing the power of his
office
these measures prevented executive
abuses
increased transparency and ethics
requirements
through campaign finance disclosure and
enhanced congressional oversight in
large part
it worked pretty well until now
president trump throughout his term of
office
has shown zero regard to the safeguards
designed
to protect our democracy and the rule of
law
in fact peace have murdered them and
today
as it was in the time of richard nixon
it is now
necessary for the congress to enact new
reforms
that restore our system of checks and
balances
an important aspect of these reforms is
to protect our elections
from foreign interference most americans
already know that if a foreign adversary
reaches out about interfering in our
elections
we should report that contact instead
the trump campaign and white house have
welcomed
and repeatedly solicited toward
assistance
for the present political activities the
protecting
our democracy act creates a duty
to report illicit offers of campaign
assistance
from foreign governments it requires
political committees
candidates and their immediate family
members
to report foreign offers of assistance
to federal authorities the bill also
clarifies that the definition of
a thing of value in the federal election
campaign act
it includes a coalition on foreign
donations
of information that is sought or
obtained from political advantage
information like opposition research and
private holding
ensures that individuals engaging in
dishonest
conduct with foreign actors that
influence the
outcome of our elections are held
accountable
the past four years has shown that the
congress
and the american people face a lawless
president
and reform is needed together the
proposals laid out by my colleagues here
today
reflect our determination to ensure
that the foundation of our democracy
enshrined in our constitution that we
sustained
for generations
let me first of all thank the
distinguished speaker
and my fellow chairs looking around my
colleagues
it occurs to me it's really remarkable
what the house committees have done
to shine a light on these this
administration's abuses
and corruption since democrats won back
the house
whether it was the president's
obstruction of the investigation
into the trump russia scandal the firing
of independent inspectors general
the administration's mishandling of the
pandemic
the mistreatment of career public
servants or of course the corruption of
our foreign policy
that led to the president's impeachment
house democrats have worked tirelessly
to demand accountability now let's be
clear
nothing we've accomplished none of the
answers we've gotten for the american
people
or the abuses that we've uncovered are
because this administration
respects congress's oversight authority
as a co-equal
branch of government it's quite the
opposite
we've been fortunate that in some cases
dedicated public servants have come
forward
public servants who knew they might face
bullying harassment
retaliation maybe even from the
president himself
that was especially true during
impeachment
but the president and those around him
think that they're above the law
and accountable to no one i've been
around here for a while now
for most of that time a subpoena was a
chairman's tool of last resort
that's because for most of that time
administrations understood
congress's oversight role even if they
weren't happy about it
trump threw all that out the window i
signed a subpoena during the impeachment
inquiry
that mike pompeo just simply ignored
i signed another one a few weeks ago and
he only capitulated once i threatened
him with contempt
a black mark that might follow him
around when he decides to run for some
other office in a few years
so how can one branch exercise
constitutional
checks and balances when another branch
doesn't seem to care about the
constitution
this behavior has set a profoundly
dangerous precedent
i hope during the next administration
the pendulum swings back
but we're not willing to take that risk
this legislation
we're offering gives our oversight tools
sharper teeth
tools to enforce our subpoenas expedited
judicial processes
fines for government officials who
refuse to comply
i hope these tools won't be necessary
but it's clear that congress needs to
stand up and reassert
our power as a co-equal friendship
government
let me now yield to the chairman of the
committee on ways and means
mr neil
thank you thanks to the speaker and
thanks to our fellow chairs for bringing
us to this moment
our founders very wisely established a
system of checks and balances
to prevent against abuses of power and
to ensure the federal government
executes the will of the people
the concept is as old as magna carta
he's as young as the american
constitution and a reminder that the
american revolution in some matter
was the ability of the people to
question the executive
ruler we are seeing a fundamental system
that is now being put to test
president trump and the administration
have sought to evade accountability and
to eliminate
transparency there is a sound reason
that in article one of our constitution
that congress is mentioned as the first
branch
of government as a co-equal branch of
the government
and our ability to conduct oversight is
a critical component of legislating
over and over again the trump
administration has sought to impede that
final work
the obstruction of our efforts to ensure
that proper and responsible
administration of federal laws and
taxpayer dollars
cannot and will not stand the package
that's being introduced today
strengthens the critical protections
that underpin our democracy one issue
that some of my colleagues have touched
upon that i also want to emphasize and
reinforce
is the role of the congressional
subpoena congressional subpoenas are not
requests
that recipients can easily brush aside
they are indispensable as a tool that
this body uses to investigate potential
wrongdoing
and inform our legislative work and to
prevent future abuses
today's legislation the protecting our
democracy act
strengthens the enforceability of
congressional subpoenas
and underscores that compliance and
remains
not simply an option the rule of law
applies to every single person in this
country
including the president and members of
the administration we are here today to
reinforce and to reiterate
our commitment to the law and our belief
in the fundamental
tenets of our democracy and our duty to
ensure
that government remains accountable to
the american people
adam
i want to thank my fellow chairs and
thank the speaker who has to
go on to other responsibilities we're
happy to take a few questions
uh before we do though i want to
acknowledge uh the work of
other members of the caucus this
package is a cumulative work product of
a great many
of our members and joining in that
effort and reflected in the bill itself
is the work of representative cohen
representative connolly representative
dean representative jeffries
representative liu
representative porter representative
raskin representative scanlon
representative speer and representative
swalwell all of whom
are also original co-sponsors of the
legislation
and with that we'll be happy to respond
to your questions
yes uh are there plans to bring up this
package
in this congress or wait until next year
i it will depend on the availability of
legislative time i would hope that we
can bring up the package this year but i
think our expectation is
whether we can bring it up this year or
not it is unlikely to move through
a senate which has uh under mcconnell's
senator mcconnell's leadership
been a willing accomplice to many of the
president's actions that have broken
down these very democratic
guard rails and institutions so we're
not temporarily optimistic but i will
say this
i think these reforms will have
bipartisan support next year
in a new administration when my gop
colleagues
will not want to see a democratic
president do half the things
of the current president so while i
don't expect to see
gop support in the senate this year uh i
do expect these will
these reforms will enjoy bipartisan
support in the future
yes uh presidential candidate joe biden
has said that he opposes hacking the
court
do you agree with him well the the issue
on the supreme court goes beyond the
scope of uh
anything in this package um so i will
leave it to the
senate counterparts to address that
issue but i will say this
the package does seek to address one of
the same problems
which is um
the the degradation of our democracy
over the last three years
three and a half years is not the work
of the president alone
um donald trump could not have
accomplished uh
what he has in terms of undermining our
democracy without the willing help of
gop
partners in the senate our system our
constitution requires
two parties to defend the institutions
of the congress and that includes a
co-equal branch of government the
supreme court
and the courts if the senate
is going to violate its own rules if
senator mcconnell is going to violate
the rule that bears his own name
and stack the court uh in the last few
weeks uh before the election
uh that will be something that the
senate will have to remedy
uh and is beyond the purview of this
package
any other questions have you you had any
time to look at
the report that came out on um hunter
biden and charisma from
kendra johnson company i had a chance to
read
the press reporting of it um and you
know all i can say is the kremlin i'm
sure is very pleased
um after all this advances a narrative
that has its origins in the kremlin and
has been propagated by
kremlin agents in ukraine like andre
dercotch
more than that as senator johnson
has repeatedly admitted the point of the
report is a
political one to have an impact on the
election and the idea
again that taxpayer resources are used
for political purposes something that we
address
in our hatch act provisions in this bill
uh but of course
if you have uh willing members of the
senate uh who are using taxpayer
resources to advance
a kremlin-originated smear
there's little we can do uh if senators
are willing to participate in that
any further questions on the bill yes
have you had any discussions with
uh vice president biden or anyone in on
his team
about whether or not he would endorse
something like this but you're creating
this as a reassertion of the
congressional power but another way to
look at it might be
in some people's eyes the erosion of
executive power is there any pushback
from them that perhaps you're stealing
their power just as they
might take the white house um you know i
think the vice president has spoken
repeatedly
uh about the priority that he places
on restoring our democratic institutions
restoring our system of checks and
balances
so while we haven't discussed the
provisions of this bill
i think he is very supportive uh of the
the concept
underlying this legislation that we need
to restore accountability and
transparency we need to strengthen
the guardrails of our democracy and i
know he has
criticized a lot of the actions that
this bill seeks to protect against
so we look forward to working with the
vice president
in what we hope and expect will be a new
administration
uh to make this law and make sure that
uh
no president can again uh violate the
rule of law the way
the current president has and how
quickly would you want to bring it up
next year under a president
well you know i view this as a as a
natural sequel to hr1
the package of reforms designed to
strengthen our franchise the
the foundational right of our democracy
is the right to vote
uh and so hr one you know very squarely
addresses
efforts to suppress the vote
disenfranchise communities of color
uh uh gerrymandering uh in the different
states
dark money in elections this i think is
a natural follow-on
to that in that it tries to protect our
democratic institutions
uh whose foundation has been laid by
that vote
now let me invite my colleagues
why do we take last question i'll invite
my colleagues to to respond to any of
the questions that have been raised thus
far yeah just to jump off of that um
vice president biden did speak with the
senate democratic caucus
last week have there been any
conversations
with the overall house democratic caucus
about what the relationship
between uh president biden and
and the house democratic caucus would be
should he win the presidency has there
been any general conversations
you know not that i'm privy to but uh
but that doesn't mean that
that isn't happening um but with that
let me
invite my colleagues if they would like
to add on to any of the
uh comments or questions that we've
heard from
from the press let me step it aside
vice president biden uh when he
served with president obama was
constantly coming to our caucus and
speaking to us
he was there was a he was friends with
so many people he had
worked on so many issues i proudly
worked with him when he
uh authored the violence against women
act so that he
has a tremendously strong relationship i
would say with
uh the congress and the senate given his
uh service uh
i uh had the occasion to hear him speak
on a zoom to some of my constituents
last night and
uh he was very strong on all of these
reform principles he didn't specifically
uh mention uh eat this bill but the soul
of our democracy
and returning us to respect in the world
and and respect for our institutions
so i think although we haven't spoken to
him just knowing his record i think
he'll be a strong supporter
of this package
thank you everyone
so
yes